les faits sont là
1-2 thompson a un meilleur bilan
économique et a présenté plus de budget
équilibré que jo or c'est aussi simple
que ça vérifications faites vous thomas
mulcair a raison mais il ne dit pas tout
un doute hansen a été ministre des
finances de la saskatchewan pendant un
an et demi soit en 2006 et en 2007 il a
présenté deux budgets qui ont affiché
respectivement des surplus de 400
millions de dollars et 2 milliards 300
millions
thomas mulcair affirme que thomson a
plus de budget équilibré que son rival
zhou enlai veut de son côté joe oliver a
présenté un seul budget à ottawa en
avril 2015 et les résultats officiels ne
seront connus qu'à l'automne 2016
on les veut prévoyez lors du dépôt du
budget un surplus de 1 milliard 400
millions de dollars
des prévisions revues à la baisse en
juillet par le directeur parlementaire
du budget en raison de la chute du prix
du pétrole
thomson rappelle qu'il est ministre de
l'énergie de la saskatchewan
quand le baril de pétrole était à 18
dollars et qu'il a été ministre des
finances lorsque le baril était à 80
dollars il a fait partie d'un
gouvernement néo démocrate qui a connu
son lot de surplus budgétaires en partie
grâce à la montée du prix des ressources
naturelles
en ce qui concerne joe oliver depuis
qu'il a succédé à jean forte le prix du
baril de pétrole a chuté de moitié
ici louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal